it is a hidden horror of an already
harrowing period at some vincent's
hospital in westchester
the pandemic drove some people away
quiet corridors that filled instead with
tales of isolation
and grief specialists at the sharp end
of the crisis have begun calling it the
silent
pandemic as those with mental health and
addiction issues
become increasingly disconnected and
unable to cope
28 year old eric bender used to come
here
five days a week for treatment things
were
looking up eric
was a drug user for 10 years and he had
been silver
for the last year he was looking for a
job
we felt he had turned the corner and
then
kovit came and he isolated in his
apartment
all by himself he couldn't see the
counselor he valued so much in person
anymore
it was just calls after self-isolating
he started to spiral he had his birthday
on
april 9th and on
may 5th he passed away from a drug
overdose
so it was a dramatic shift in his life
covered 19. it was dramatic and he is
collateral damage
if the pandemic hadn't come eric would
be alive
what do you want people to know i love
derek
and he worked real hard but he didn't
make it
and there's nothing to be ashamed of
in fact we're rather proud
that he did work so hard
he died after taking cocaine laced with
fentanyl a synthetic opioid
his mother firmly believes he didn't
intend to die
but like so many his physical and
emotional
tolerance was tested a lot of our
patients are experiencing
grief and loss unexpectedly that they
didn't anticipate experiencing coming
into march
loss of a job loss of a family member
loss of
sense of purpose and identity we've just
seen
more severe illness and a spike of it
and then we've also not been able to see
patients in person
group interaction is considered a key
part of getting better but that is still
not an option
when covid came all of a sudden people
who were used to
reconnecting with peers and people and
and uh socializing again were all of a
sudden forced into isolation
and that was the hardest part so many
people got
sad they got depressed their best friend
all of a sudden was a drug of choice
we saw a lot of people uh returning to
use struggling with relapse
and ultimately overdoses just you know
skyrocketing
from my own experience i know three
people personally
who died within one week
in may there was a 48 rise in suspected
overdoses in america compared to the
previous year
and here has been a sharp increase in
new people needing mental health support
their doors are open they want people to
come and they're finding new ways to
treat them
but there is no quick fix and months
maybe
years of struggle ahead cordelia lynch
sky news harrison new york